- I'm amazed by people's abilities
to build companies or incredible art.
But for me to admire someone
that means they've done something
that really touched my soul.
(beat drops)
You got your perspective.
(electronic music)
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
- Gary Vaynerchuk, hey, how's it going?
- It's going well, how are you?
- I'm doing good, Gary.
- Good.
- So, Gary, this is a podcast recording
for the Mindvalley podcast.
But, one of the things that
we do a little bit differently
is that we have a live
audience watching us.
So we have about 170 people right now.
It'll probably go up to about 300 people.
And the audience, these are
Mindvalley's biggest fans
have been helping me come
up with questions for you.
First, how's it going?
How are you doing?
I know the world has
been so different lately.
- I lean into gratitude and perspective
and accountability during these times.
And that's it.
That's all I can do.
- Well, one thing I got
to say about you, Gary,
is that I love the positivity
that you bring on stage.
So just a little backstory
but I remember about a year ago,
we were speaking on stage together in,
in Sharjah, near Dubai, right?
You opened the conference,
I closed the conference.
But what really touched me,
is how when you got on
stage at that audience,
in Sharjah, you were able
to adapt your message,
adapt your style, to an Arab
audience so effortlessly.
- Thank you for saying that.
- And at the same time, I've
seen you speak in Vegas,
and it's a completely different GaryVee.
This was at Tony Robbins'
Business Freedom Mastery Summit,
way, way back.
We've shared the stage several times,
but we've only met once, at a pizza joint,
in Summit series, many
years ago aboard a ship.
But I just want to express my gratitude
for having you as a guest here.
- Thank you for having me.
- I've been watching you
for 10 years and amazed
at how you've grown.
Now because of how,
when you speak, Gary,
you just go on a roll.
So I do not want to interrupt
you in unnecessary questions.
I want to give you a space
to share your message
to our audience today.
The people who are watching are mostly,
60% leaders, managers, entrepreneurs,
and they are all here as part
of the Mindvalley community
because they love personal growth.
And these 300 people showed
up live because they love you.
- It's very sweet.
I'm so excited to be here.
Let's rock and roll.
- So with everything happening
in the world right now,
what would be your
advice to entrepreneurs?
- You know, I think it is going into...
You know what's funny, when I
just answered your question,
I realized if I organize...
this literally how I create content,
this crew will probably see
a video tonight at 7:30 PM,
Eastern American time,
where the title at the
top is going to say,
go into your GAP during times like this.
Because serendipitously, I
decided to answer you with,
you know, with gratitude
accountability, and perspective.
I ordered it differently,
but as you and I were talking
I reordered it into spelling the word GAP.
So, I'm actually going to
make that a piece of content.
Like I literally have
just decided right here,
serendipitous, never put
those words together.
So, that's fun. And it's
an insight to how I think.
Which is like, creativity, information,
being skilled at something,
it requires omnipresence.
You know, you can go train,
like I can go train to be a skier,
but I'm not going to
be a world class skier.
For me, entrepreneurship,
and really wisdom and
perspective, came natural to me.
It's my natural state.
So, you know, what do
I tell entrepreneurs?
I tell them, this is
what you signed up for.
Like, to really go there.
What I tell fellow entrepreneurs
is like, this is our time.
Like when things are challenging,
when they're difficult,
when they're not stable,
is exactly when entrepreneurs do well.
A pure, a real entrepreneur,
I don't like using the word real,
but like, an entrepreneur,
not someone over the last
decade, when it got cooler,
decided they wanted to be one.
But an entrepreneur,
it's like being a fish,
and now here's the water.
Like to me, this is our time.
This is when you have to navigate.
This is all we know.
Like, you've signed up for a world where
you have to react to
realities on a daily basis
and it's all on your
accountable shoulders.
And then when they're
incapable of going there,
I deploy perspective and gratitude.
I remind my friends, some
who've been struggling,
that if COVID started six weeks earlier,
Kobe Bryant would be alive.
You know, you can decide
to look at all the bad.
Go look at the traffic
deaths data around the world.
You know, you start getting
into scary debates of,
were more people's lives saved
during this time than lost?
It's half glass full, half glass empty.
You start getting into really interesting,
thoughtful places.
And so for me, it's perspective.
You know, I think about World War II.
I think about the Black Plague.
I think about so many genocides.
I think about the people
and the millions of people
around the world that don't
have clean water every day.
Not when there's not COVID.
I'm not capable of
dwelling because of GAP.
You know, gratitude, accountability,
like what am I going to do
about it, and perspective.
And so I'm, what do I say?
I say, we should be thankful
that we can even have this conversation,
health over everything.
And let's, you know, let's move forward.
- I love that GAP concept.
So gratitude, we get gratitude.
Tell us about accountability.
- Accountability is tricky,
because people confuse accountability
with lack of compassion.
And I don't see it that way.
You know, I view accountability
as, what can I control?
And so, you know, when
things like this happen,
people blame.
People want to blame China.
People want to blame their own government.
People want to blame their
boss, their spouse, the system.
And oftentimes there's
validity in those things.
The question becomes, what
are you going to do about it?
You know, you can go political
and talk about voting.
You can talk about people
that are in really suppressed
places about leaving,
if they can.
You know, some places
you can't even leave,
but leaving, if you can.
You know, for me, it's accountability.
What can I do?
You know, when a lot of our,
in a very small, not
as heady conversation,
when my company is in trouble,
when COVID hits 'cause
clients are telling us
they're not going to pay,
they have to reduce scopes.
You know, first I stopped paying myself.
Then I stop wasting money on dumb stuff.
So I look at all our expenses.
Then, unfortunately,
the worst of the bunch.
I have to let some people go,
so the whole company can pay its bills.
You know, life.
And so, I like accountability.
I like, you know, what am
I going to do about it?
And I don't think it's fun
or healthy to feel helpless.
And I think it leads
to a lot of bad things.
That doesn't mean that
I don't have compassion
for people that are in
precarious positions.
It's just that I think
it's very empowering
for people to try to hack
to think, what are they going to do?
- Now, the final one
was perspective, the P.
- We've already touched on that, which is,
I use perspective and gratitude a lot.
My perspective leads to gratitude,
you know?
- Ah hah, right.
- It could be worse, right?
My perspective is it could be worse.
- So then, as you went
through this disruptive period
what was some of the life lessons,
the big insights that you gained?
- I got affirmation from who I think I am.
During ironically, oh
my God, today is 9/11.
So 9/11 was the first major event
I had to navigate through, as a leader.
I was a very young kid
in a family business.
Then there was the
great recession in 2008.
These are macro things.
As an entrepreneur and
operator, every day,
you're dealing with micro things:
lawsuits, somebody's family's
issues, clients, employees...
But macro, 9/11. Great recession.
But I always, in the back
of my mind, my friend,
knew one thing.
9/11 I was a kid.
I had, you know, I had no expenses.
The great recession, you know,
the reality was I built
the business for my dad,
not for myself the first time.
So, even in 2008, I really
didn't have a lot, you know?
I had an apartment, but
not a whole, whole lot.
I didn't have kids yet.
So I always knew in the back
of my mind that I got...
I was a great entrepreneur
and I was fearless
and I put everything on my back,
but I really didn't have a lot to lose.
So I always wondered, what would happen?
Not what would, when the
next big thing happens,
this is me five years ago, four years ago,
three years ago...
When that happens, am I going
to be as good navigating
when I'm clearly losing things?
Money, leisure, you know, who knows what?
Status. Whatever it may be. Fun.
And the biggest thing I learned is,
I'm built for this shit.
I'm born for this.
You know? I went right into
the place where I needed to be.
I knew what my requirement
was as a leader.
So I got affirmation of
my intuition of who I am.
And I think I'm a wartime general.
I think I'm at my best
when it's most adverse.
And I think that's because I
grew up in adverse situations.
So that was nice,
so that was something I've learned.
I've learned that people are,
I was affirmed my suspicion
that people were soft and entitled.
You know, this is where
I keep going back to GAP.
You know, like, people...
we're not entitled to
have everything come easy.
I don't know why people think we are.
It's not part of the life journey.
Like, look at history, you know?
Bad things happen.
And like, really, really
bad things happen.
And I think people have
become too materialistic
and have gotten complicated
in their need for acknowledgement
from outside forces
based on commercial successes,
or what car they drive, status.
We're a very deeply, globally, globally,
a very deeply
insecure animal.
And we need other people's
opinions for validation.
And I wish people could get
validation from their process.
Not from the things that their
process allows them to buy
to make them look good to others.
So, you know,
I've learned some human
truths that were suspicions.
And I also learned that
every situation's different.
I'm speaking in generalities right now.
There's 7 billion people.
Plenty of people have excelled.
Plenty of people don't
need a BMW to look cool,
they just like how it drives.
You know, more affirmation
around me knowing
that there are thematics
I'm passionate about,
and I'm sharing them now,
but every individual is different,
going through their own cycle.
And I have a lot of compassion
and empathy for that.
- That's amazing.
That's beautiful.
So the audience, we now
have 500 people live,
the audience has a series
of questions for you.
Can we take some questions
from the audience, Gary?
- Of course.
- So the first question
is from Jason Whalser.
Do you still believe in the hustle?
- Absolutely.
Now, I think the word, when
I used it in 2009 a lot,
meant hard work.
- Mm hmm.
- I think the word has
been manipulated in society
in the last half decade to mean burnout.
And so I've switched using
it, more in a world of like,
you know, when a word changes its meaning
to a large group of people,
you have to acknowledge that.
So, I use the word work ethic a lot more.
I will forever believe in work ethic.
There's nothing accomplished
without the execution.
And I believe in work ethic.
Not to the expense of someone's
health or mental status,
but I'm a very, very big advocate.
I would argue that I believe
in work ethic more today
than I did a decade ago.
- So if you have to break it down, right?
When you say work ethic, what
does that look like for you?
Like, you know, how you
came up with that acronym
GAP, what's work ethic for you?
- It's like, we can all agree that there's
a certain amount of liquid
in this bucket, right?
- Uh huh
- To me that's work ethic.
Like, everyone in here and,
reading these incredible
comments, observations, questions,
everybody in here is
got different skill sets
in different things.
So if I put in seven hours a
day into learning how to cook,
over time, I could be a
much, much better cook,
but I may not be as great as Jason Holzer
or Jan McKinney or Anna.
Cause they just actually had talent
along with their work ethics.
So there is a talent, work ethic thing.
But, it takes an enormous amount
of work to be Beyonce or LeBron.
And/or, probably every
single person, here, right?
Every one of us are
going to really struggle
to not recognize that the
hours put into our craft,
our execution, the time
you put into your children,
your employees, making this,
trying to figure out the formula for this.
Like, you know, for me, it's listening.
I spend so much time listening.
You know, everybody sees
me talking all the time,
but I spend 90% of my time listening.
It's why I have early
observations on things.
And so, I work at that.
That's me putting in four hours last night
reading Twitter, Instagram,
forums, Reddit...
Like, I read people's comments,
that's why I have a pulse.
I'm an anthropologist.
I'm a strategist that way.
So, you know, I believe in it.
I believe it's putting in the work.
It's it's like pushups.
I think everyone here
working on their craft,
and things of that nature,
doing push-ups, if you do eight
them, certain things happen.
If you do 80 of them a day,
a different thing happens.
Now we all have different
muscle composition.
So some of us may show more
but the work is the work is the work.
It does matter.
- Oh my God
That is so interesting.
Because 10 years ago, 10
years ago, you told me
that you literally respond
to every customer email.
Like back then it was email, right?
This was like 10 years ago
when you were running Wine Library TV.
- And by the way, my friend,
the reason the Gary Vee thing happened
was the four years on Twitter,
where I replied to
everybody who tweeted me
and reached out to people
talking about wine,
and then social media.
Like, there is no people know who I am
without the work I put
in to establish context.
And then my upside was predicated
on how much value I was providing.
I put in the work.
But if all the things I've
been saying through the years
was to get people to come into my funnel
and sign up for my course,
or if I wasn't doing the
right thing by people,
or, you know, I have the receipts,
they're all on the internet.
You go look back at my
stuff that I talked about
in '09,'10, '11', '12, '13...
A remarkable percentage became true.
That's going to give me affirmation
of a reputation.
- Right.
- You know, people talk
about personal brand
and then people are
like, I hate that term.
I'm like call it what you want.
It's called your reputation.
You know, me being right
about a lot of things
was better for me than me
being wrong about those things.
- Okay, so this is insane,
because when you told me about
how you respond to every
single email, I was like,
I was incredulous.
I was like, yeah, right now,
but that's not going to sustain
itself 10 years from now.
And here we are 10 years later,
and you just told me you spent four hours
replying on Instagram.
- Oh, last night, correct.
- Last night, right.
- Now, that was a little different.
Similar, but different.
Last night I was reading
comments about subject matters.
I did reply to some of
my stuff, to your point.
It was not... you know, I
remember when I was doing it,
everyone's like, it's not
sustainable. I'm like,
and then it won't be.
- Right.
- I didn't have my pride in it.
I knew that it was a nice thing to do.
I was learning.
I was making connections.
I always to this day, I think this way.
This is why hopefully,
if some of you've met me,
you've gotten a sense of me.
I will never big time anybody.
I came from the dirt. The dirt.
I don't have it in me
to big time somebody.
I promise you, every time
somebody says Gary Vee,
I'm so grateful.
I'm so flattered.
You know?
And so I will never take that for granted
that somebody appreciates my work.
I will never, I will go to the grave.
And by the way, on the record,
I don't even think I've started yet.
- I love that statement.
- I really am telling you the truth.
Like, as you know, 10 years ago
I started making some juice.
I'd already built a big
business for my dad,
so I had some credibility.
And I mean, I'm in a totally
different stratosphere
than I was back then.
And that's exactly how I feel right now
of who I'm going to be at 54
because I think, I have good intent.
I believe in what doing.
I'm working hard.
I'm working fair.
I'm doing the things that,
you know, lead to good things
- Gary, what is it that
really matters to you?
Like what is it that you wake
up every day excited to do
and to give to the world?
- I have this weird blend
of guilt and gratitude
that I was gifted circumstances
and an ability to communicate.
And I want to leave that.
I want to leave that.
I want that legacy, selfishly.
I'm addicted to admiration, right?
And I think that
admiration is only earned.
You don't, you know,
admiration doesn't come...
let me rephrase.
My definition of admiration is,
you don't get admiration
unless you really do something
really meaningful, deep.
Like, I'm amazed by athletes.
I'm amazed by certain
people's general beauty.
I'm amazed by people's
abilities to build companies
or incredible art.
But for me to admire someone,
that means they've done something
that really touched my soul.
Like, they're incredibly just,
kind and generous.
And their humanity is on
a scale above the rest.
And I'm very focused on
trying to create that.
Now, that comes at the contrast
of being a businessman.
That's not where the world
is looking at businesses,
but it is my truth.
I love doing business.
And I love nice.
I'm addicted to nice.
So I want to leave a legacy
where people feel compelled
to come to my funeral one day,
or tell their daughter a story,
or whatever the social
network of the day is,
or however we communicate, you know,
to say something nice.
I want to do that.
I want to live that life.
That is super interesting to me.
- That's beautiful.
Beautiful. I love that.
And you definitely resonate kindness.
I've noticed that about
you, a number of times.
So here's a question from Adam.
- Please.
- Adam is asking,
I've been following you for two years now.
Wonderful to to see
you here on Mindvalley.
What advice do you have for people
starting a new career midlife?
- Contextualize that you're early.
I think a lot of people,
when they think midlife,
don't realize how early that is,
and they feel this pressure
that they need this to work.
Once you take the pressure out,
that you might make this
switch, and it might not work,
which you can then go
back to the old thing,
or try a third thing,
if you could eliminate that pressure
because it's about calibrating time.
If you have a good relationship
with time and realize,
how old is he, if you could, was it Adam?
I'm sorry, I didn't...
- Yeah Adam, how old are you?
Post it in the comments.
- You know, I want to see it for context.
And maybe it's not even for him.
Adam, if it's not for you,
if it's for your mom or
dad or somebody else,
put the number of that age.
- 41.
- Yeah. And Adam,
is it for you? You can just
say yes or what have you.
You know, like, to me, if
it's for Adam, let's say,
at 41 years old, he's uncomfortably young.
- Mm.
- There's a really good
chance, on a conservative day,
he's got 25 years of
profession in front of him,
which is more time than
he's already put in
since he was 18 to 22.
Think about that.
But that's not what we do, my friend.
We don't do that.
We do not do a good job in
having a relationship with time.
We think at 41 we're old,
'cause society has done a very bad job
of creating time.
'Cause we're going off of old norms
where people did live to 50 or 60.
But we're living to 80, 90 and 100.
And because of our health
and wellness initiatives,
as a global society, we at 41,
and mentally the
youthification of our society,
all of a sudden 41 is really 25,
but nobody feels that.
And so, that's my biggest advice
which is take the pressure out.
You know, when I see Amber at 34 in here.
Like, fuck man, I look
at 34 and I'm like, ugh!
By the way, I restarted my life at 34.
At 34, I had spent my
entire life, 12 years,
building a business for my
dad, in a family business.
I didn't get paid what I was worth.
I built a business from
three to 65 million.
I was never making any real money at all
because it was a family business.
You know, you inherit
it when your dad dies.
I leave at 34.
I own nothing.
I don't own the Wine Library.
I have no money on
paper to borrow it even.
But I fucking built it.
So I've had this huge
12 year accomplishment.
And what I get for it, is
to start over with zero.
And I'm thrilled because I
accomplished what I wanted
which is, I wanted to do
something great for my parents.
That took humility and patience.
I'm at 34, I start VaynerMedia
in the conference room
of Buddy Media, 'cause
I don't have any money
for us to pay rent.
- I did not know that.
- So I started over at 34.
- Wow. And VaynerMedia,
what year was that?
That must have been 2009, 2010, right?
- That's right, I was born in '75.
- Wow, wow. You're about
a year older than me.
- You know, and so,
this goes back to excuses
and accountability.
Sometimes I meet people that are like,
"yeah, but your dad handed you something."
I'm like, "that's what you've
manipulated my story into."
Let me tell you the truth.
- That is so interesting.
Firstly, so much respect for you.
I did not know that part of your story.
- Well I'll tell you
why you don't know it.
Let me tell you why, but
let me take it even further.
You know why you don't know it?
- Why?
- Because I didn't want to make,
I thought when I started getting notoriety
that I didn't want to tell that story,
because I thought that it didn't
shed good light on my dad.
- Uh huh, right.
- I thought that some people
would take it as like,
my dad fucked me.
- Right.
- Because I'm an immigrant,
and I know that our framework
is different than the masses.
- Yeah, you were born in Belarus.
- That's right.
So I didn't want to, you
know, I love my parents.
Right? Like, and then
it became a detriment
because you can imagine,
after you do that,
to live a life where people
try to throw an excuse at you,
that the reason you were successful
is you were given something.
When I was part of the very small .0001%
that gave to my parents.
Fuck you.
- Right. Oh my God.
That's a beautiful aspect of your story.
Yeah, a lot of people don't
know you were born in Belarus.
If you Google Gary,
you'll see American
Belarusian entrepreneur.
My ex-wife was from Belarus,
so I...
- You know the culture.
- By the way, with everything
happening in Belarus,
do you feel a connection to that?
- I do, but my parents fear
me being too loud about it.
Because, you know, dictate...
the Soviet Union scared
families, scared people.
- Yeah, yeah. I know what that's like.
Gary, the next thing I want to ask you is,
as you spoke about age and
our perspective of age,
one of the things I realized
that I'm biased about is TikTok.
You've been raving about TikTok.
My six-year-old daughter
came up to me a week ago
and she said, daddy, you
need to be on TikTok.
And I have an 11-year-old
friend who can teach you.
And, so in my mind,
TikTok is like for kids.
You are 45 and you are
crushing it on TikTok.
Tell us about that.
Why is TikTok relevant?
- It's relevant because,
A: every platform that ever
becomes a big platform,
often starts young and then ages up.
You know, don't forget everybody,
there's not a 17-year-old on Earth,
a 20-year-old on Earth that
wants a Facebook account.
And it used to be the most
important place 10 years ago.
So for me, when something emerges
and has that scale of attention,
I'm always gonna go look at it
because I'm a strategist
for not only myself,
but for everything I do in business.
I might start a candy
company, or a sneaker company,
so I need to know what's going on TikTok.
Two, I need to know how to use it,
so I always put myself
in that environment.
Three, what's happened on TikTok,
is what's going on on TikTok, which is,
it is now dominant for
20, 30 and 40 year olds,
at scale, across the globe.
So, and that is with
enormous amounts of effort
from different governments
to try to paint it
as an extremely dangerous app
doing things that you don't understand.
There's been an incredible amount
of media and government efforts,
India, America and other
superpowers against it,
and still, the consumer continues
to speak with its behavior.
You can imagine how much it's
resonating with the consumer.
I don't have emotion.
I don't feel like my
opinions on social networks
should be other people's opinions.
And I respect people's opinions.
I also ask them to explain.
I've had tons of
conversations, they're like,
tell me how TikTok's dangerous.
Well, it's China and they know what?
There's not spyware going into your phone.
We can prove that, you can look.
So, it's those kinds of questions.
- I see, I see.
So, in terms of entrepreneurship today,
what would be your advice to entrepreneurs
in terms of building their personal brand?
Getting their message out?
If they just don't feel comfortable
getting in front of a camera
or sharing their voice?
- Find out if you're comfortable
in a medium that does work for you.
Because a lot of people
don't feel comfortable
in front of a camera,
and I understand that.
Insecurity about the way one looks
is a huge thing for the world.
Genuinely enjoying privacy
and not wanting to be known out there.
Like if there's a million
reasons why, and that's amazing.
Maybe you should write.
Writing is an incredible way.
Writing blog posts, writing copy.
Maybe you're a photographer
and you can write a couple sentences,
so all of the sudden Instagram works.
Maybe you don't like to talk in camera,
but you love to talk,
and you can record it
and you can build a huge podcast.
Find a medium that does work for you.
And oh, by the way,
if nothing can be found,
then that's okay too.
You're just leaving a lot
of opportunity on the table,
and that's okay too, right?
- Mm. Yeah. Yeah.
- Important point.
And you know, this is
what's fun about maturing.
I find myself articulating
things out loud now,
that I used to think people understood
and were assumed when I talked.
So I looked back at old content,
I'm like, mm, I was more definitive.
Like, it was these
absolute hard statements.
And I thought that, and wrongfully,
that it was contextualized
through the breadth
of everything I was saying.
Now I think I'm more thoughtful
of delivering what I just said, which was,
find a medium.
Oh, by the way, if you can't, that's okay.
You know, but recognize,
much like work ethic,
you're going to leave some
opportunity on the table,
and guess what?
If you want to build a great business,
plenty of people build it without
building a personal brand.
Now, if you build it,
it will lead to things.
Not to mention the thing
that I'm doing it for.
My great, great, great great grandkids
are going to really, really know me.
- (laughing)
- No I mean this, I mean this.
Like, yes, I like the fact
that Gary Vee brings business
for VaynerMedia and other things.
That's good.
But that's tiny.
What I really like is,
when I'm 87 and I give some
advice to my granddaughter,
she's gonna be able to go
back and look at something
I said in 2015, that was consistent
to something I'm telling her in 2064.
And I think it's gonna land better,
because she's not gonna
think old grandad is just
trying to fucking tell her that.
She's gonna be like, fuck,
this guy really believes that.
- I love that.
I love that.
But Gary, don't you think it's
getting way too competitive
with social media?
You have people like Jay Shetty...
- Of course. Of course.
- They have mastered it into a science.
- Of course.
That's good.
It should be merit-based.
- But doesn't that set the bar
so high for the rest of us?
- No, no.
It just means that what you're gonna get
is what you're gonna get.
That would have happened
if those people were alive or not.
The world is abundant.
Let there be no confusion.
Me and anybody else,
we are not taking eyeballs away from you.
There are plenty of eyeballs.
That's just the truth.
- Right, I like that perspective.
- It's just true.
You know, it's just true.
The question you just
asked is the same question
I was asked two years ago, four years ago,
six years ago, eight years ago.
And there's many more people on now
and I'll be asked them again in 20 years,
and it's still going
to be the same answer.
The world is abundant.
You are gonna get what you're gonna get.
I've met a lot of people, they're like,
"Ugh, that influencer
is taking my audience."
I'm like, first of all,
it's not your audience.
The audience is the audience.
Nobody owns anything.
Number two, there are 7.7
billion people on Earth.
There's plenty of audience for you.
And if you're bringing value
and somebody else is bringing value,
in a similar genre, because
no two people are the same,
they're gonna consume both.
Actually, good job, Sarama.
They're gonna consume both.
- That's great.
Okay. So Kimberly asked,
and Gary I don't know
how much time you have.
- I have my, I have my internal
team on a Zoom here now.
So I want to sneak one
quick one in right now.
But, last one, I apologize.
- So, the final question
here is on kindness.
Kimberly says, she's so appreciative
that you preach the mantra of kindness.
But Andrew Casey asks, how do you deal
with people who try to take
advantage of your kindness?
- Nobody can take advantage of kindness.
People take advantage of people
that allow them to take advantage.
And let me explain that,
'cause it's very subtle.
I hear this a lot and
it's a great question,
thank you for it.
You're not being taken advantage
of because you're kind.
You're being taken advantage of
because of two things.
One, and this one really hurts
people when I pick at them,
especially usually
one-on-one with a friend,
is because you're letting
them take advantage of you,
because you're expecting
something on the backend,
and that was your way to get them in.
And when they don't deliver on it,
because you weren't candorous,
you blame them, not yourself.
Or, you're wildly insecure
and need affirmation.
And so you're just letting
someone take advantage of you,
to feel a quick adrenaline rush
or a hit of appreciation,
'cause you yourself are hurting.
Those are the only two things.
You're either trying to manipulate
somebody subconsciously,
or maybe consciously.
Or two, you yourself are
not in a strong place,
and you need a quick
feeling of appreciation,
even though you know,
deep down it's not true,
and then it hurts in the end.
Those are the only times
you get taken advantage.
Not because you're kind.
I'm the kindest, ah man,
I'm real kind out here,
and I'm not getting
taken advantage of ever.
- Amazing, Gary.
Gary, thank you so much.
We know you got to run.
Thanks for making this
appearance at Mindvalley.
- Really, by the way, kudos
to you on this format,
the app, the pushback, the curiosities,
the doubling down, the
affirmation of the attendees
during this brought an incredible dynamic.
Similar to why I really
enjoy public speaking.
And I can't thank you
enough for innovating.
I think it's a great
format and kudos to you.
And for all of you that
were commenting here,
real real love.
Please feel free to say
hello, any platform,
I know you can find me.
Bye everyone.
- Thanks. Thank you, Gary.
- Hey, everybody on YouTube.
First of all, thank you so much.
So humbled for your time.
I don't wear a watch, but
time is the biggest asset
so thank you for watching that video.
If, you got some value out of that,
there's plenty more where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.